Here's the reduction of
3 CNF SAT to SUBSET-SUM.
I'm going to illustrate the reduction
with an example, because writing out
the transformation in it's full
generality can get a little messy.
Even with just an example,
it may not be clear why I'm making some
of the intermediate steps at the time,
it should all become clear at the end,
however.
We're going to create a table with
columns for the variables, and
columns for the clauses.
The rows of the table are going to
be the numbers in our subset.
We'll have this column
represent the one's place,
this one the ten's place, and so forth.
The collection of numbers
will consist of two for
every variable in the formula.
One that we include when Xi is true.
We'll notate that with Yi, and
one that include when Xi bar is true.
We'll notate that with Zi.
In the end,
we want to include either Yi or Zi for
every i since we have to assign
the variable Xi one way or another.
To get a satisfying assignment we
also have to satisfy each clause.
So we want the numbers Yi and
Zi to reflect which clauses
are satisfied, as well.
Here then, is how we fill out the table.
Y1 sets X1 to be true.
So we put a 1 in that column,
to indicate that choosing
Y1 means assigning X1.
And this also satisfies clauses 1 and
3 since that's where X1 appears.
Including Z1 we'd also assign
the variable X1 a value, but
it wouldn't satisfy any of the clauses.
So all these are written as 0s.
We do the analogous procedure for
Y2 and Z2.
The literal X2 appears
in the first clause, and
the literal X2 bar appears
in clauses 2 and 3.
And we do the same for
the variables X3 and X4.
These then are the numbers that
we want to include in our set A.
Now, we need to choose
our desired total k.
For each of the variable clauses,
the desired total is exactly 1.
We assign each variable one way or
the other.
For these clause columns however,
the total just has to be greater than 0.
We just need one literal in
the clause to be true in order for
the clause to be satisfied.
But that doesn't give me a specific
k that we need to sum to.
The trick is to add more
numbers to the table.
These all have 0s in the place
corresponding to the variables.
In exactly 1,1 in a column for
our clause.
Each clause j gets 2 numbers
that have a 1 in that column.
We'll call them gj and
hj, so thus, g2 and
h2 have a 1 in the column for
c2, and 0s everywhere else.
This allows us to set the desired
number to be 3 in the clause columns.
Given a satisfying assignment,
the corresponding choice of Y and
Z numbers will have at least a 1 in all
the clause columns, but not more than 3.
All the 1s and 2s can be boosted up
by including the g and h numbers.
Note that if some clause is unsatisfied,
then including the g and
h numbers isn't enough
to bring the total to 3.
Because they're only two of them.
So there's the construction.
For each variable include one
of the two variables, Y or
Z, which will correspond
to the truth setting.
And for each clause include g and h, so
as to boost up this total in
the clause column to 3 where needed.
This construction just
involves a few four loops.
So it's easy to see that
the construction of the set of numbers
is polynomial time.